Apple's iMac hasn't really changed much
in the past few years with only a small
speck update last year without any
physical changes but now there are some
rumors pointing to a new 2020 iMac
coming sometime this year
so in this video we're gonna talk about
those rumors as well as a couple of
personal reasons why we think we should
expect a new 2020 iMac and we'll also
discuss the top six features you should
expect to see in this new iMac late last
month rumors of a new gaming focused
MacBook or iMac popped up from the
Chinese economic daily news site the
rumors claimed that Apple has plans to
launch an eSports computer this year
with a price of up to five thousand
dollars at this year's WWDC conference
in June which could be a large screen
all-in-one computer like the iMac this
might seem like a bit of a stretch but
Apple has recently been focusing more on
the video gaming space by creating the
Apple arcade so it seems like Apple has
finally realized how large the gaming
industry really is now I personally
don't think that Apple will market it as
a gaming Mac I think it'll just be a new
2020 iMac that's gonna be packin
hardware that will be excellent for
gaming this will allow them to further
market their Apple arcade and make even
more power demanding games Apple has
also been working on their project
catalyst which basically makes it easier
for iOS developers to port their apps
over to the Mac for example the popular
iOS racing game asphalt 9 has recently
been ported to the Mac using catalyst
this means the Apple could give us a new
update on project catalyst this year at
WWDC and announced that a bunch of
third-party game developers are starting
to move their games over to Mac if this
happens a new iMac that has the hardware
to support high-end games will actually
make a lot of sense but for those of you
who don't really care about gaming let's
move on to the top six features we
should expect in the 2020 iMac refresh
first of all we believe that most of the
new features are going to be coming to
the larger 27-inch 5k iMac in the 4k
version will more or less stay the same
or only see a bit of the updates so for
these new features we're gonna focus on
the 5k iMac one thing we can definitely
expect is Apple to offer the new AM
Navi based graphics options which is the
graphics that come packed into the 16
inch MacBook Pro we should probably
expect to see the 5500 as base maybe the
5600 XT and at the high end a 5700 SD
card these new graphics perform
extremely well for gaming and also well
for other graphics heavy tasks like
video editing for number two it's been a
very long time since the physical
display has been refreshed so we think
that this is finally the year to see it
happen this will come in the form of
slammed down bezels possibly making the
overall size of the iMac smaller to fit
the same display size or Apple bumping
the display size up to 28 or 29 inches
if they keep the same form factor
there's also the chance that they'll
increase the refresh rate to make it
more gamer friendly but that doesn't
seem as likely for the third feature we
should definitely expect to see Intel's
latest high-end 10th generation
processors now some Windows laptops are
already coming with these but they're
low-end chips we believe the iMac will
be one of the first computers to come
with these new higher-end tention chips
this will greatly increase efficiency
and we should expect to see a very high
performance 10 core option on the
top-end model this would also be a great
match for the high-end 5700 XT that
could be coming in this iMac for feature
number 4 we should expect to see better
cooling on the iMac possibly the same
dual fan cooling system that's in the
current 2017 iMac pro this will be very
important if the 2020 iMac is going to
be packing such powerful hardware and
especially important if this Mac will
end up being a gaming focused computer
hopefully Apple will figure out a way to
keep the RAM accessible and user
upgradeable alongside the new cooling
updates for feature number 5 we expect
Apple to finally get rid of the fusion
drive as a standard storage drive and
offer only SSD storage like the rest of
their Mac's this will most likely only
happen on the 27-inch 5k iMac and not
the 4k models since they're more focused
for the budget-minded
these SSDs offer reliable and very fast
performance to make sure it's always
running at its full potential especially
with the upcoming powerful processor and
graphics and finally we have feature
number 6 one of the biggest drawbacks of
the current iMac is that it doesn't
Compaq
with the t2 chip this means it gets much
worse performance for HEV see video
editing and it's not as secure as the
rest of apples Macs the reason the
current iMac doesn't have this chip is
because it's meant to work with SSDs and
since Apple still offers fusion drives
on the 5k iMac they couldn't really
implement the chip so if the 20/20 5k
iMac switches over to SSDs only we
should expect it to come with either a
t2 chip or maybe even a brand new
updated t3 chip that takes care of more
tasks this will also pave the road to
Apple finally getting rid of hacking
Tosh's by requiring Mac OS to check for
this t2 chip to allow it to run but this
will happen for another few years so
there you have it those are some of the
features that we expect to see in the
new 20/20 iMac now there is a chance
that Apple could skip this year
altogether but we'd really like to see
it happen this year if you have some
features you'd like to see coming to the
20/20 iMac let us know by commenting
down below and if you're not already
subscribed click that circle above to do
so right now thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]